monsieur escande
nous avons appris ce matin qu'après deux
mois de répétitions et à 15 jours de la
générale robert hirsch e renonçait à son
rôle de don césar de bazan dans ruy blas
pouvez vous nous en donner les raisons
n'ont rien de bien grave
simplement quand deux fortes
personnalités comme celle de monsieur
rouleau et celle de monsieur hirsch se
heurtent ils arriveraient pas que ça
plaisait à celle vous imaginez bien ils
n'avaient pas la même conception du
personnage et robert yeux ce très
intelligemment et très gentiment a
préféré renoncer au rôle que de suivre
les directives il faut bien le dire de
monsieur rouleau
ce n'est pas extrêmement grave pour la
comédie française malgré l'immense
talent de robert hirsch dans cette
maison vous avez il n'y a pas de vedette
s'il ya des acteurs est une troupe
complet d'ailleurs nous avions tout
prévu puisque depuis longtemps il ya
plusieurs distributions de rue place que
par exemple monsieur phal qu'on va jouer
lui-même rue place dans quelques jours à
la place de monsieur des soupes il a
préféré laisser à son jeune camarade la
joie de jouer en premier d'autre part
monsieur sommet doit jouer long service
à la place de monsieur ries et monsieur
jean cas dont vous connaissez le très
grand talent aussi avaient été
distribués dans césar de bazan et jean
piat comment avez vous appris la
nouvelle que vous remplaciez robert
hirsch
hier matin par téléphone
l'administrateur m'a téléphoné raymond
rouleau aussi moi m'ont demandé de venir
très vite au théâtre j'ai cru comprendre
qu'il se passait quelque chose j'ai
entendu je suis venu
les deux m'ont dit ben voila tu répètes
demain alors j'ai acheté cette nouvelle
vous a pris au dépourvu par seulement
puisque avant les vacances avant de
partir en vacances
j'avais déjà eu des contacts ses
nombreux avec raymond rouleau pour le
rôle dans ses oeuvres auxquelles j'étais
destinée après robert puisque la tournée
la colonie française qui part pour
l'amérique du nord en février m'a obligé
à remplacer robert dès le mois février
prochain donc au fond je joue un peu
plus tôt que prévu je gagne 4 mois sur
le terme et malgré tout je pense que
vous restez vos amis avec chambéry et
robert en question la boxe
[Musique]